Nevers and simply learn to get ahead
Jess Danish a civil engineer turned data
scientist who decided to Simply learn
possible with a course from a premier
[Music]
University direction true champion who
upskilled to win
big how big a massive hike that
transformed my life Danish changed gears
pretty early in the race but brusson
wanted to explore more to get ahead isar
simply learned from mechanical
engineering to a data analyst and a
podcaster in his free time career
transformation simply learn industry
expert data
expert with a well structured course it
felt like a piece of cake that is simply
awesome what's also awesome is that long
didn't choose a quick fix he just added
data science into the
mix nithan how did you change the game
worked on real industry problems to
become the real deal a joint family a
regular job responsibilities but nothing
could stop nin from getting ahead what
an allrounder de Hoya night with
flexible learning you can always make it
right passion
situation you will find your way to get
ahead when you simply
learn simply learn get ahead with simply
[Music]
learn
hi folks uh we'll be starting the free
career master class uh pretty soon in
sometime uh meanwhile I can see a lot of
introductions coming on chat so good
evening good morning good afternoon
where wherever you're joining us from uh
I'm your host Rasha Khan for today's
webinar and I'm joining from Bangalore
India and I'm thrilled to be a host
today so drop us a hello and let us know
where are you tuning in from so I can
see folks have already started
introducing themselves on chat I can see
folks have joined from uh Kenya I can
see Norman has joined from Kenya I can
see Rajiv has joined from
Kolkata I can see sha has joined from
Delhi I can see obid has joined from
South Africa I can
see Nathaniel has joined from Ghana so
again once again welcome everyone keep
the introductions coming in uh it's
always good to network right these
events before we
start
awesome I can see folks have joined from
different different parts of the world
so the basically it's we're having a
global conversation here on chat so uh
once again like welcome everyone it's
fantastic to have you all on board uh
for the free master class uh we'll be
talking about why cloud computing is the
right career for you in
2024 and we'll be starting in few
minutes meanwhile I uh I can see folks
are still joining in and basically
giving their introductions on chat uh in
case like if you're giving introduction
uh we are not able to make out your name
from email ID please do mention your
name as well I see a lot of folks are
mentioning their name as well I can see
Angela has joined from Ethiopia Simone
has joined from Nigeria Emanuel from
Nigeria I can see Muhammad has joined
from
Pakistan I can see Alfred has joined
from South Africa but he is in at the
moment I can see Scott has joined from
Chicago and Moses has joined from K so
once again welcome everyone I'm your
host for today's webinar my name is
Rasha Khan for folks who have just
joined right
now and uh we're just waiting for a few
more minutes and just having like an
engaging conversation on chat here
before we
start
awesome awesome awesome keep the
introductions coming in and uh just a
quick tip for folks who have already
joined early uh that in case you have
any questions about cloud computing
career in general you can let us know in
the Q&A box so I'm pretty sure you all
joined the session because you're
curious about careers in cloud computing
and I'm pretty sure you have a lot of uh
questions about that and you can
basically put on your queries in the Q&A
box and I will make sure that all of
your ques are
answered awesome as I was speaking I've
already see that folks have already put
down their questions in the Q&A box here
so that that's great you guys have come
prepared I can see that so once again I
see a lot of folks new folks have also
joined as we were speaking so we're just
doing a quick round of introductions
here before we start uh so I'm rashak
Khan I'm your host for today's webinar
and I'm joining from all the way from
Bangalore India would love to know where
are you joining uh from on the chat here
as you can see uh folks are introducing
themselves on chat and they have joined
from different different parts of the
world I can see shimang has joined from
Nigeria say has joined from India uh has
joined from Nigeria and I can see hash
has joined from Pune
bhat and I can see Bola has joined from
Sweden uh and uh and I see a lot of
introductions coming in here so uh let's
start with few ground rules here uh you
as I mentioned earlier for folks have
just joined right now that if you have
any questions for our speaker here today
you can always put down your questions
in the Q&A box and uh the session is
being recorded in case you have any uh
basically questions if you missed any
part of the session you can always
expect a followup email from us uh with
a recording link and also bonus offer
for attend this webinar for the program
part basically Avail that bonus offer
for the program which I'll be uh
explaining towards the end of the
session and also to request a proof of
attends for this webinar you can provide
your name in the post webinar survey
that is something you'll be getting over
mail once the webinar is done and uh U
so the today's program is powered by uh
simply learn world's number one online
boot camp
and we are very proud We have been in
the digital skills space in for almost
last 13 years and uh we have advanced
over five lakh plus careers in over 150
plus countries and we have some 800 plus
qualified trainers uh who basically make
sure that you know you are basically
transforming your life through uh these
programs here we have a lot of
categories like AI machine learning
business etic cyber security and today
we'll be covering the cloud computing
one so if you have any questions please
do let us know in the Q&A box let's
quickly go through the agenda here uh
we'll be uh getting to know a little bit
more about you how we can basically help
you out better in your cloud computing
care career and answer all of your
queries you know of um as I can see that
folks have already started putting
questions in the Q&A box that's great
and we'll be talking about cloud
computing careers uh and how calch ctma
helps you the program uh and we'll be
talking about learner outcomes of the
CTIC uh postgraduate program in cloud
computing and also taking you through
the enrollment steps and there will be a
special duration for the Q&A part so we
will try to take as many questions as
possible throughout the session uh but
just in case we are not able to answer
all of your queries uh throughout the
session because we have a limited time
right we have only like 60 Minutes to
cover so what we'll do is we'll take it
towards the end so just keep your
questions relevant and keep it related
to cloud computing that's the only
request we have and I'll make sure that
all of your queries are answered so uh
once again thank you so much everyone
for joining so uh before we start uh as
I mentioned that let's get to know each
other a little better so you can see a
quick poll on your screen here uh which
says that how many years of experience
do you currently have so uh and you can
see four quick options here the first
one currently studying second one 0 to 3
years third one 3 to five years and the
last one more than five years and I was
as I was speaking folks have already
started sharing their responses in the
poll yeah that's great we have gotten a
really active audience
here and I can see the introductions
coming in on chat like here as well so
that's great that's great we have gotten
a really active audience here and uh
we'll be starting the session just after
this just after this quick experience Po
and we already have our speaker
purushotam here with us so where are you
joining us from yeah hi rash so I'm
joining from India Maharashtra basically
nagpur yeah oh nice nice nice welcome
purushotam once again thank you for
taking the time out for this Ker master
class uh let's see let's just give like
10 seconds more for the experience for
here just to understand what are the
folks you know what experience do the
folks have you know who are joining us
uh in this session today so I'll just
give five seconds more uh because I can
see most of the folks have already
shared the resp on the poll so uh five 4
3 2 1 let me quickly end the poll and
share the results with
you let's see like what are the results
so we can see that 3 4% of the folks are
currently studying and just the opposite
30% of the folks have more than five
years of experience so basically we've
gotten uh basically huge timel of
experience here folks joing from
different different experiences here and
32% of the folks have Z to three years
of experience and few of the folks have
three to five years of experience so um
thank you so much for sharing that with
us and uh we'll move on to a speaker
introduction today uh so Dr purushotam
asani has joined us for taking through
the career Master Class basically what
you can expect in cloud computing
careers in 2024 uh so uh Dr purushotam
once again like welcome to the session
and uh please give us your introduction
for the crowd here we would love to know
more about you sure thank you so hello
everyone and welcome to the class today
thanks Rasha for inviting me so um I'm
working as an assistant professor in
information technology department in Sri
Ram DEA College of engineering and
management nagpur I specialize in cloud
computing uh Microsoft Azure AWS and
operating systems I'm a Google Scholar
corporate trainer have delivered
multiple corporate trainings on um
public Cloud platforms like Azure AWS
and gcp um associated with multiple
world-class consultancies like simply
learn also associated with calch
universities many iits for delivering
the postgraduate program in cloud
computing um I'm a Microsoft certified
trainer AWS certified trainer AWS
certified Solutions architect
professional which is the top level
certification on AWS in the architect
domain three times AWS certified
Microsoft Azure certified um yeah Oracle
certified Associates um so that's in
short about me yeah thank you uh thank
you so much Dr purushotam for your
introduction uh and uh let's move on to
the session here so let's talk about
careers in cloud computing so uh as we
can see that cloud has become the
backbone of the digital economy here
today so uh Dr purushotam can you share
your comments on uh Cloud being the
backbone of the digal economy today yeah
actually see um now uh cloud has become
the backbone of digital economy uh why
because see um it is almost in every
sector uh not just in it but then um uh
like it is almost in every sector made
be marketing made be cross made be every
anything or everything cloud is
everywhere guys because um whenever it
comes to storing your data or the
servers uh so it's always um a costly
Affair to have it in your on premisis
environment then to have it in the cloud
especially in the public Cloud platforms
like AWS and assure or gcp these are the
market leaders basically and um it's
it's it's predicted that by 2025 almost
90% of the companies will move towards
Cloud see the uh big mnc's are already
in cloud and um they they they do use
cloud computing to save a lot of uh uh
their exp uh expenses uh to save a lot
of the costing uh and to of course Avail
a lot of uh Advanced features that the
cloud providers uh provide us okay apart
from that even the startups um now let's
say tomorrow if one has to have his own
startup so um he can he can very easily
can have it in the cloud rather than
having it in the on premisis environment
uh a person I mean um a complete company
can be set it up in cloud correct so
that's the beauty of the cloud so in
that way uh people can actually save a
lot of uh their expenses
and they can just benefit from the
features of the cloud and uh have their
complete environment complete
organization running in Cloud platform
and that's that's how it has become the
backbone of the digital economy today
yeah uh well that sounds pretty
interesting uh of a career so thank you
so much for answering that and taking
you through the cloud computing uh
digital economy you know back so here uh
as we can see there are so many career
paths uh cloud computing opens up in the
year 2024 here so uh would you like to
take us through these career Parts which
folk can explore just apart from
becoming just a cloud computing engineer
there are so many CER parts we can take
up right so basically keeping in mind
the next year to 2024 uh folks are
aspiring to become a cloud computing
expert so uh what what would you
basically share for them what career
part would take up in the next coming
year yes surely right so uh see if you
are new towards Cloud uh well you can
start your journey in Cloud um by by
learning uh the introductory courses
first on the cloud platforms uh like in
AWS AWS um fundamentals like AWS
practitioner and in Azure Azure
fundamentals and then you can go with uh
the administrator courses and the
architect courses and you can become a
cloud engineer to start with okay by
doing these courses uh yes so that is
the way uh forward to go into uh
especially if you trying to get into
Cloud by 2024 you can start your journey
in Cloud by by learning uh let's say in
AWS AWS practitioner then uh ssops admin
or then architect and you can become a
cloud engineer okay and yes if you are a
database guy if you are interested in
the database stuff um yeah if you're
already a database engineer or have good
Hands-On on database in the on premisis
environment well then in Cloud uh you
can get into the database role you can
get into uh like database related
services and certifications like you
have um uh Big Data speciality in AWS uh
database engineer you can become so then
you can uh try to become Cloud database
administrator okay and uh if you are if
you are a coding guy if if if you love
coding and you're you're pretty good in
in the programming side then you can you
can try to go for cloud developer role
wherein uh you can uh you can do uh
developer related certifications on AWS
or Azure like in Azure you can go with
Microsoft Azure a204 um that is aure
developer associate or in AWS you can go
with AWS developer associate correct so
um that way you can become a cloud
developer okay uh if you are if you
eying for a developer certification in
AWS well you should uh have good good
handson in in in Java programming and
then on on Azure you should be good
maybe in in in Net Framework corre
correct so that's there sorry then um if
you are a security guy guys if you are
interested in security and you are
already maybe working as an on premis
security engineer or or or or you are
interested in security related Services
then you can go for security related
stuff in cloud like in AWS you can go
for AWS um security speciality
certification and or in Azure also you
can go for a 400 security certification
um and apart from that even if you go
with architect courses or admin courses
you will learn about security aspects so
that way you can you can um go with such
courses and you can try to become a
cloud security engineer and yes of
course if you're already working as an
architect or if you have good good good
experience um um good number of working
years of experience okay and and if
you're already maybe working as a cloud
engineer or you're not working as a
cloud engineer but you're uh you're
working in the architect role or if you
have good number of years of working
experience then you can uh go and become
a cloud architect and for this uh you
can try to achieve um let's say cloud
related architect related certifications
on AWS like AWS certified uh Solutions
architect associate or architect
professional uh means after associate
you can go with professional or AWS or
sorry Azure certified um architect that
is a305 and uh yes uh you can become an
architect that way even if you go with
architect certifications and if you
don't have good good number of years of
experience then you can go with Cloud
engineer role as well correct uh so that
is how you can go about it and yes guys
if you are a devop sky if you
are uh into building the continuous
integration continuous deployment
pipelines if you're a devops engineer or
plan to get into that role uh you want
to do automation stuff then uh you can
go with um devops related services in
AWS or aure like you can create your own
continuous integration continuous depl
deployment pipeline by cicd services
like code commit code uh deploy code
build kind of services in AWS like
similarly the services in open source
you have like genkins and terraform and
stuff so you can go with such services
and then you can become a cloud devops
engineer yeah so there are there are
multiple roles uh you can go with
correct now so so based on your interest
and your likings uh you can go with the
related services and you can you can opt
for the um particular role in
Cloud well that are uh you know like
many roles uh you know folks can take up
in cloud computing 2024 uh thank you so
much for taking us through that Dr also
would like to add Rasha sorry to
interrupt see uh as you rightly said
that there are so many roles so yeah so
if you're thinking that okay maybe u in
Cloud I can only be uh like get get into
one leral or one uh particular role so
that's not the case like whatever you
have it in the on premises you have it
in the cloud and uh so so so there are
so many roles let's say for example if a
person is uh U is interested into
programming is a coder uh is is a coding
uh guy so he can get into developer uh
role correct but if a person is not good
into coding because many of time people
do have this myth that in IT industry if
you're not good in coding well you
cannot get into it so that is not a uh
not actually the fact is okay so even if
you're not a good de good coder even if
you are not a developer you can get into
it still and then you can get into Cloud
because there are so many other
letterers that are still available for
you uh yeah thank you so much Dr Pam for
answering that and also we are getting a
lot of messages on chat here folks would
request you to please put down that in
the Q&A box uh so we can take up those
questions because we don't want to miss
out your questions here uh which I can
see a lot of introductions coming in uh
as we talk about the career paths here
uh as we you know so are the salaries
right so as we can see here this salary
being the most important part you know
when you're basically aspiring for a
career in cloud computing uh so as we
can see here we have gotten this Source
from Glo here so the annual salary for
cloud depers in India specifically uh
the highest uh is maximum is 22 lakhs
INR and the lowest is five lakh when
you're starting off and also similarly
for uh Cloud Architects here in India uh
the maximum salary uh they can get is 33
lakhs and uh they can get the lowest
when they're starting off as 10 lakhs
the mid-range for both of them are
between 10 to 20 lakhs so that is salary
being an important part here so I want
to frankly ask you that if you are
aspiring for a career in cloud computing
so can you expect to get paid
good for sure I mean see uh these
numbers are anyways decent enough here
but um I would like to tell you uh see
if you are if you are becoming a cloud
engineer um see even the low ones as you
can see as five lakhs and 10 lakhs so
those are the ones that you can start
off with and then once you start in and
you do good into this domain so then
there's there are like hardly any
boundaries that you can have even that
33 lakh that you have mentioned like I
have my own friend um earning more than
45 lakhs per n he's a he's an architect
he's a cloud architect um though he's
having a good good number of years of
experience so then uh the point that I
want to mention is uh even the highest
that is mentioned here is not the
highest uh the the things go beyond that
as well so
um I mean the uh best way uh to get into
it uh is to get into through cloud or if
you're already in it uh you can just
transition your future um into Cloud
because cloud is there to stay guys um
yeah yeah so that's definitely
definitely uh I think we have gotten one
question uh which basically is quite
interesting that how artificial
intelligence will impact the cloud
computing industry in the times
ahead okay uh uh yeah so see artificial
intelligence is will impact the cloud
computing industry means AI is already
there in the cloud even if you talk
about Azure or AWS or any of these
Market leaders Cloud platforms so they
are having a lot of great related uh
Services related to Ai and machine
learning that are already there um just
to name a few maybe if you go into AWS
and if you go into ml Services machine
learning services so you have a lot of
them already there like you have AWS
recognition which will recognize uh the
objects from the images very accurately
then transcribe service is there which
would convert your speech into text and
that too also it's very accurate then
poly service is there um which would
which would convert the text into speech
okay um so you have a lot of machine
learning related Services AI related
Services already there and the more the
AI will mature uh the more the offerings
the cloud providers will give you
related to AI correct and and um it's
it's see even nowadays also in Cloud
it's all about automation also like when
when you get into devops it's about uh
the automation Journey you create your
cicd pipeline things happens
automatically whenever you change your
code in the repository the codes get
deployed onto the platforms like your
ec2 or the VMS um in an automated
fashion so so so so so automation is
already there and AI related uh services
are already there and as the uh as the
AI gets more matured so those uh things
are getting integrated or will get
integrated into the cloud platforms uh
so
yeah uh thank you so much for answering
that uh sham I hope that answers your
question uh please do let us know in
chat here in the Q&A box if you have a
followup question for uh us uh meanwhile
as we be talking about the career paths
here and also the salaries in cloud
computing uh we can't miss out the
skills right the skills basically which
are required to become a cloud
practitioner so as we can see there are
so many skills folks can start with uh
but like what would you suggest someone
you know we have gotten a question in
the Q&A box that how do you start like
you know where do you start what skills
they can start with if they are
basically aspiring to you know go
towards a cloud competing career correct
so I would like to start this as you
rightly said that uh I mean uh we saw
about the salary part but we really
cannot miss on the skills part because
that is real important and um let me
tell you guys I mean don't think about
salary part I would say um uh just
concentrate on the skills and the salary
would I mean automatically will come to
you it's all about the skills if you
have the skills if you have that neck U
so of course the things are going to
follow for you correct so uh that's
there so uh as far as the skills are
concerned of course um to start off with
or um uh to to to start uh how would you
get into cloud like uh how would you
start with so you should start with the
basic fundamental scores into cloud like
uh in AWS I would say you should should
start with AWS practitioner
certification which covers the Jack of
many services like it it will cover the
introductory part of many services may
not be the detailing of all but then yes
the know how of many services and then
in assure the similar service you I mean
the similar certification you have got
is azure fundamentals e at 900 okay so
you should start with that first and by
doing that you get to uh know that what
are the different Services how they work
you get to know the knowhow of cloud how
it works how the things are there and
stuff like that so you get into uh like
a good space wherein you can figure out
that okay this is something that is of
my interest or I I can be good getting
into Cloud platform correct once you are
through with that then you can always um
um go for the certification as per your
role or your interest like if you are an
admin guy you can go with admin related
certifications like is at10 4 asure
administrator associate or uh awss SS
admin and if you if you want to become
an architect or you want to become a
general Cloud engineer when you want to
have the uh design related um U
decisions you need to take so you can go
with AWS architect associate or aure
architect correct and uh if you are a
developer or you to get into that role
then you can go with developer
certification and so on so so first you
should go with the basics that is AWS
practitioner or aure fundamental and
then you can get into a certification or
get into the um particular uh uh lateral
uh that suits you or that is of your
interest correct like admin or sis subs
or maybe uh the network engineer or
architect and so on correct so that is
there so um so you should first have the
cloud provider selection like which one
you can start with so I would suggest
you can start with ews or assure first
and then you can go and get into the
other Cloud also because see today is
the era of multicloud platform uh I mean
you will hardly see a company working on
the services of just one Cloud platform
uh now if a company is there they would
use some services from let's say AWS
some services from Azure so um probably
you should have the knowledge of
multiple clouds and let me tell you uh
Azure AWS being the market leader so
normally whenever a company thinks of
moving towards cloud or multic clouds
these are the obvious choices that they
go with so you can start with AWS aure
first and then follow up with the other
one so cloud provider selection uh that
way you can meet and of course um when
you study about architect related
services or admin you will see about
application migration how you can
migrate your application from on
premises to AWS performance testing in
cloud cloud workloads how you can move
how you can work on that in Cloud IM am
means identity access management so how
uh this is specially useful for an
administrator uh guy uh like how can you
create your users in cloud like a
company can have multiple user accounts
so how you can have multiple user
accounts how you can grant them roles to
different Services okay so that they can
do certain task like a network engineer
can operate with networking related
services and and database admin can
operate to database related services and
so on so that can be done with IM
identity access management plus if you
want to in autoscaling you study about
uh let's say balancing the load across
your VMS and um let's say with uh sale
days like Flipkart Amazon on uh they do
have their sale days correct guys so
during their sale days the traffic on
their website is not the same it shoots
up so how to uh how to cater to that
traffic so the number of instances the
servers on which the website is running
should increase so that can be done in
an automated fashion using Auto scaling
and when the sale days are off they
should be automatically reduced so that
you don't have to pay for them when not
required so that again can be done with
autoscaling correct then you have
disaster recovery so Disaster Recovery
is in uh like um
uh let's say if you want to plan for Dr
purposes Disaster Recovery purposes when
you can plan for it let's say if you
have your website running in in in one
country let's say India location and or
let's say any any country it is running
because the users are from that country
but then uh if if if God forbid guys if
there is a natural disaster in some uh X
region and your website was running on
the servers in that region then the
website uh May crash completely okay and
the data may not be available so in
those cases you can have your website
data you can have your servers
replicated in another region um so that
during the in case of disaster also when
complete region goes down well the
servers in that region will go down but
then the website may be running on on
another servers in another region also
so so the website can still be active
during that time correct so uh you can
plan for Disaster Recovery that way and
for that you have good services like in
aure you have Recovery Services Vault
correct um in AWS also you have cross
Regional application to take care of
that you can have your web services and
API in Cloud you can host your websites
in Cloud you can go with Cloud migration
and deployment you can actually migrate
your complete data from on premisis
environment to Cloud let's say in Azure
you can do it with Azure migrate correct
um if you have petabytes of data or
exabytes of data in AWS you can do it
with snowball device offline data
transfer pretty quickly if you have
hexaba data okay so snowball device may
not work it's just like a CPU so then
you can go with snowmobile that's kind
of a truck that comes to your place so
in fact they say that probably the data
exabytes of data which would which would
have otherwise taken let's say 26 years
to migrate that data from on premisis
environment to Cloud can be done um with
with with snowmobile devices in a matter
of less than six months okay so that's
the beauty so that way you can migrate
um yeah you can have your database
manage in Cloud multicloud deploy
deployment I already told you plus you
have storage services like uh you have
uh you can store any kind of data and
any amounts of data in cloud like you
can store U object related data blog
based data uh shared file storage data
in Cloud so you have services for that
like you have S3 for object related data
EBS volumes for Block based data EFS and
FSX uh the services in AWS for for file
uh shares storage data correct so you
have a solution for everything I here
yeah uh thank you so much Dr Pam for
taking us through a detail explanation
of these skills in cloud computing also
U just just a question here basically uh
what would be the most in demand skill
in 2024 for someone who basically is
thinking of a cloud computing career so
what would you see as a in demand skill
or and also a career path okay so in
demand skill as in incloud correct yes
yeah okay uh see in demand skill as in
in Cloud um now there are multiple leral
so I would say uh it's it's it's
difficult to say one uh but then uh what
I really feel like uh is that if you
become a cloud devops engineer well that
is something in thing is okay so I would
rate the devops engineer role uh to be
the in thing okay in 2024 for okay
because it it deals with automation okay
and um apart devops engineer and if you
get into the uh machine learning and uh
the database speciality big data and
machine learning speciality in Cloud
well these are uh going to Boom up I
think yeah and as far as the architect
role is concerned it's it's kind of an
evergreen thing okay so it would there
but then the boom uh the hype uh that
would be created would be in these roles
I would say well that that sounds
interesting uh please do let us know
folks if you have any questions about uh
cloud computing careers in general you
know in 2024 please do let us know if
you have any questions about that we'll
be taking those questions and also we
are getting a lot of questions in the
Q&A box we'll be taking those pretty
soon meanwhile we have talked about the
skills here we have talked about the
career paths you can take up in cloud
computing we have talked about the
salaries uh in cloud computing uh as a
fresher as an expert we have talked
about what is the most in demand skill
and a career path in cloud computing so
what exactly is stopping you from
becoming a cloud computing expert so uh
you're here obviously so you're
interested in cloud computing you
obviously are aspiring towards a career
in cloud computing but we would love to
know what is the biggest challenge here
so we can help you out better uh as we
move on to the program uh preview here
of uh calex pgp cloud computing uh
program so uh you can see four quick
options here uh so these are the ones we
have basically put up we feel like okay
these are the most suitable ones but
obviously you can let us know on chat
here or in the Q&A box as well uh if
basically it does not basically cover
your points here so uh I can see as I
was speaking folks have already started
sharing the responses on the poll here
so this one is a multiple choice
question so you can select multiple
options here because there can be
multiple concerns right which is
stopping you from becoming a cloud
computing expert so I'll just give 10
seconds more because I can see most of
the folks have already shared the
responses on the board so that's great
uh as I mentioned earlier we have gotten
a really active uh audience here and uh
an active set of Learners I would say so
uh also I'll just give 10 seconds for
the poll but I'm just wanted to point
out once again that uh folks I
understand you have a lot of questions
but uh as you're putting down your
questions in the chat box we actually
will miss it because we're getting a lot
of questions there so that is why we
have basically a designated place for
the questions here that is the Q&A part
you can just go and quickly just copy P
the same query on the Q&A part that that
is just beside the chat box here so uh
okay I think I'll just also read out the
options here for folks who are still uh
basically uh you know left out in in
this response of the poll here so what
exactly is stopping you from becoming a
cloud computing expert the first option
here is I can't find a program with a
fully comprehensive curriculum here and
the second option I wouldn't get the
Practical exposure I need to become job
ready and the third one I find it
difficult to learn from pre-recorded
videos and the last one my work schedule
won't allow me enough time for learning
so uh I'll just give five seconds more
for a few of the folks who are left
because you would love to know what
exactly is your biggest concern biggest
challenge here so we can help you out
better uh with the upcoming program
toping points so I'll just give five
seconds more so five 4 3 2 1 let me
quickly end the poll and also share the
results with you folks uh so as we can
see that we have gotten the highest
amount of votes 51% votes for the second
option here that I wouldn't get the
Practical exposure I need to become job
ready and 43% of the folks have voted
for I can't find a program with a fully
comprehensive curriculum and uh 22% of
the folks have voted for I find
difficult to learn from pre-recorded
videos and 24% of the folks have voted
for my work schedule for alomi TR for
learning I think uh we get that because
most of the folks who have joined us
have quite a lot of amount of experience
so that makes sense now moving on to the
program part here
moving on to the program part here uh so
CTIC post graduate program in cloud
computing here comes with comes with an
industry online learning path and uh you
get integrated Hands-On labs and
projects which you can basically add
onto your portfolio here when you're
basically trying to get out there and
get a job in cloud computing uh and
other career paths in general to it and
you get access to online virtual
classrooms and also this program will be
flexible to fit your schedule because
this program duration is of 11 months
but you can just complete it by giving
10 to 15 hours per week uh so Dr pusham
I just have one question about the
learning environment here of the program
so uh what is the kind of interaction
which happens between an instructor and
and a peer because it's a live virtual
classroom right so what do we see
happening there like what have you seen
basically what is the experience that
students have had can you share a little
bit about that yeah sure so basically I
would be um very good in sharing that
because I've been taking these classes
uh for the PG program in Cloud computer
yeah so uh basically see it's a live
class uh we have a 4our uh session and
in that uh normally what uh we follow
especially I follow is um I'll go
through a topic and then uh we will have
the concepts of that topic then the lab
related stuff on that topic and then
whatever the questions that comes up um
probably in the chat window so let me
tell you like today there are a lot of
participants and we do have a timing
constraint so may not be we are not
answering the questions there itself
right now but then during my live
classes whenever the question comes in
the chat window I have the neck of
answering the questions then and there
itself okay if not then and there itself
maybe I'm in the in the middle of some
topic I'll finish that topic off and
then we'll answer those questions okay
so it is not like I'll go to the end of
the session and then I'll answer the
questions because it's a 4-Hour class
and then probably if I would answer it
at the end of the session then um
participants may miss on the uh like the
concept of that particular topic so uh
between that topic itself then and there
itself or after finishing that topic we
do answer the questions um so that's how
we go about it and many of times we do
also give our Learners uh to do the
Hands-On activity along with us and if
they come up with any doubt we we we do
Sol it uh during that time also at times
it has also happened like we we
sometimes get the participant screen
also and we we do um sort their issue
out uh during the session itself so
normally they put their queries in the
chat window we do answer it if it is not
getting solved uh through the chat
window or maybe they are having an
advanced query we do unmute them as well
and they ask their queries and we do
answer it so that's how it goes so it's
an Interactive Learning basically so the
problem of uh having a pre-recorded
sessions and not having the interaction
is is totally not there it's totally
gone that way okay so it's it's purely
interactive session wherein uh the
Learners would learn while the trainer
would explain okay uh so that's how it
goes uh I think I can I can speak for
that because I've seen your sessions
here even in Project demo sessions you
have done right and uh even though it
will take longer time but you make sure
to answer all of the questions
throughout the session and it kind of
gives a sense of you know basically how
basically you your uh learning
environment will look like so I can
speak for that FKS here for Dr pusham
live virtual classrooms here so U and
and at end of it all you will be getting
a CTIC uh ctm pgp certification here you
can see on the screen here uh this will
be a postgraduate program certification
by CTIC in cloud computing and uh you
will be getting access to over 40
projects for your portfolio including a
Capstone one which we'll be talking
about in the upcoming slides and also
someone has asked about the curriculum
we'll be talking about that you know Dr
B will be taking you through that in in
detail and we'll be receiving up to 30 C
from calch ctme that is equalent to 300
hours of learning and calch ctm
membership which is again like uh Clos
nit circle of alumni basically who come
from diverse Industries uh diverse
basically companies also and basically
the Learners which we had in the past
you know have consisted of you basically
folks joining from different different
uh companies and industries as well so
it makes it pretty interesting to be a
part of that Circle and an online
convocation so in an online convocation
setting uh you can not only invite your
closest family or closest friends but
also your far relatives and far friends
and and uh basically this does not
happen in an offline setting and this
make makes it equally interesting you
know the online convocation part by
Caltech here and also a job assist uh
program through simply learn which I'll
be talking more about in the upcoming
slides so uh folks you have any question
about the program here you can let us
know in the Q&A box and also um if
basically you have questions about cloud
computing General you can let us know
the q& Box because we'll be taking those
questions pretty soon here so let's talk
about the calch CDMA advantage here so
the California Institute of Technology
is a 13 year old institution it's a very
old institution here uh and basically
having a CTIC ctme name on your CV is a
very prestigious accomplishment
recognized worldwide and CTIC conly
ranks in the top five universities
worldwide and also is a home of uh to a
lot of Alma matters of you know many no
objects uh so Dr pushan just want to ask
like about the calch CM Advantage here
so what do you think like uh the CTIC uh
basically acts as an advantage for
someone basically taking up this course
what have you seen basically in your
classes we know when they have completed
the program what is the CTIC Advantage
part here maybe in a very short answer
you can let us know see it's it's it's
actually huge I would say because um
when you have celtech written on your CV
it adds a lot okay um probably U it is
celtech as I have seen it's it's it's
ranked among the top five universities
along uh around the globe okay um and
one of my relatives only uh like last
year he was trying to get into the
undergraduate program of CCH University
somehow he couldn't make it last year
but he's trying to get into this year so
uh the point is that if you have that
keltech CME in your uh in your resume
well that adds a lot okay that that
itself speaks because uh that's the
brand value uh that one um aims for
isn't it yes yes yes yes definitely and
uh that is the CTIC CD CDM Advantage for
you folks here uh now I think someone
has asked about the eligibility and
prequisites for this program so I'll
just take take you through quickly here
and uh so basically you may be from a
non-programming background uh that is
okay and you need to have a bachelor's
degree with at least 50% marks and no
work experience is required here so uh
if you basically don't have a prior work
experience uh in any field or even in
cloud computing that is totally you can
take up this program and start fresh uh
so like just a quick question once again
like Dr Pam like as it says like you may
be from a non-programming background so
what level of programming uh knowledge
is expected to take up this program see
if you want to become a developer in
Cloud developer associate is at24 aure
developer or ews developer associate
then you should be having the
programming uh knowledge for sure
without that don't go for that developer
certification but yes if you if you're
not going for that developer
certification then of course uh
programming knowledge even if you don't
have that's not a problem because that
is not required um the small uh stuff in
in architect or Sops admin the uh
programming related small stuff if at
all required during that program that
would be covered during the program
itself but then yeah for those kind of
courses u a non-programming background
is preferred like it's it's it's it's
perfectly okay that's not a problem uh
thank you so much for answering that Dr
puram I think we have gotten a few
questions uh in the Q&A work that
definitely answers that uh now moving on
how this program basically prepares you
I think folks have asked about the
curriculum part maybe you can give them
a little glimpse of you know what
exactly happens in the program and how
exactly It prepares them so let's talk
about how the program builds uh you know
that cloud skill step by
step right uh so uh see when you get
into the PG program postgraduate program
in cloud computing it starts off with
the orientation session session for
cloud computing program uh wherein um an
orientation session would be taken for
you you would be given the idea of what
would be covered in the course and uh
stuff related to that and then uh you
would get into so that's an introductory
lecture you will get into then you get
into AWS Solutions architect course so
uh that will prepare you for the
architect role on AWS architect
certification in AWS okay uh basically
uh this AWS Cloud fundamentals would
come before WS architect and then AWS
architect would come okay and so in
fundamentals as I told you you will have
the knowhow about the services in AWS
and then you would go with AWS Solutions
architect um and then uh you move to
Azure because as I told you that the era
is of multic clouds and when you talk
about multic clouds um the market
leaders are AWS and aure so once you
once you complete AWS stuff then you get
into Azure role and then in Azure uh the
compulsory courses that you need to
study or you will study is first one is
azure administrator that is
a104 in that you will get the Practical
knowhow about the different Services you
will study different Services uh do the
handson on that the lab scenario based
Labs you will do into it and then you
get into the architect domain on Azure
that is
a305 okay so that's basically Azure
architect and uh uh so so so so that
that will help you make uh take design
design decisions in in Azure and uh do
the architect related stuff on Azure and
then you have got this good part now
added to this that you have then devops
on AWS so because devops as I already
told you that uh it can be the happening
thing in 2024 okay uh going ahead um
probably the high rated skill okay so uh
devops on AWS so devops related services
like uh Cloud uh uh formation Cloud uh
Cloud deploy
uh um um then code deploy code pipeline
code commit those Services you'll study
and then you can deploy your own
continuous integration continuous
deployment pipeline you can do
automation on AWS with devops on AWS so
uh those things you'll study and then um
so basically what is devops on AWS it's
like it's an automation on AWS let's say
if you have some code in AWS repository
let's say code commit or GitHub uh then
it would be automatically deployed on
your ec2 instances and if you make some
change in that code then again the
changes will be automatically deployed
onto your ec2 instances or uh your uh
Computing platforms whatever it is so
you don't have to manually do it it
would be automated the activity correct
so that's what you do it in devop so you
can become an automation engineer that
way also and then finally you can um you
go with a cloud computing Capstone
project so this Capstone project will
cover about the AWS and Azure related
Services together okay U so it's a
complete end to endend um Deployable um
realtime Deployable project that will
include the services of AWS and Azure
both and that way you will complete that
Capstone project and see during these
projects every course will have its own
project also wherein the uh trainer
would Mentor you how you can do it plus
the Capstone project would be mentored
as well okay and then there will be
assignments as well and once you finish
all these things guys so after the end
of every course you will get a
certification from Simply learn a
certificate from Simply learn and when
you'll complete all these courses so
then you will get that coed um u u
Caltech certificate that is
post-graduate program in cloud computing
from Caltech University okay and apart
from that apart from all these
compulsory courses you have the elective
courses also now these elective courses
um comes for no extra cost uh whatever
the cost you have it uh for these
compulsory courses for the program in
that these electives also are are
included for electives these are not
mandatory you can opt for one or all of
these electives okay so that's how it
goes and in the electives you have cloud
computing academic master class so that
is taken by um The Faculty from ctech
itself which you can attend uh then you
have AWS developer associate Sops
associate data migration Google Cloud
platform architect training and devops
on cloud correct so all those are there
yeah so this is how you will be getting
it step by step uh thank you thank you
so much Dr P for taking us through the
steps for program how it basically
builds your cloud computing skills also
talking about the electives of the
program here so uh the electives here
are cloud cloud computing academic
master classes which you can attend uh
and AWS developer associate AWS asops
associate AWS data migration uh Google
Cloud platform arketing training you'll
be getting access to and Dev Ops and
Cloud as well so these are electives
these are optional they come as a part
of the program so you don't have to pay
anything extra for that it is up to you
if you want to take it up uh but yeah
there are very interesting electives I
must say so to take up in this program
now uh talking about the tools and
platforms you'll be learning in the
program Dr purushotam so um I think U we
have a question here from shubam who
basically is asking to what extent Linux
knowledge is needed to be actually ready
to be become a good Cloud professional
so I think maybe you can answer that and
also cover the tools and
you know platforms we have here correct
so yeah so Linux knowledge see if you'll
ask me yeah if you have Linux knowledge
good it is an advantage and then uh you
should be having at least the basic
knowledge of Linux um if you want to be
in uh let's say uh if you want to
specially go into the AWS domain but
don't worry uh even if you join this
course um you would be given uh the
knoow of Linux or the some uh self-paced
course that you can do on Linux and then
you can op for this but yes if you have
if you don't have knowledge on Linux you
can still study this but if you have
knowledge on Linux then it is an added
Advantage it is a good thing to have it
correct so yeah uh and basic knowledge
of Linux is good enough you you need not
have to be a master on that basic
knowledge of Linux should be good enough
especially for AWS okay and now tools
and platforms you will learn uh so of
course um these are just few services
that are mentioned here guys really just
few but if you get into the course you
will learn a lot of services out of
which few are these ones like you will
you will learn the computer related
services on AWS like ec2 elastic
computer Cloud which which you can
create your virtual machines in AWS or
Lambda function um that is serverless uh
elastic beam stock so these are computer
related Services then you will also
study about the database related
services like data uh for no SQL data
you can get it stored in Amazon Dynam DB
that is the nosql data base service in
AWS or for relational data you can get
into RDS relational database service and
so on okay so um that is there Lambda I
already talked about that comes under
compute service okay uh wherein you
don't create the servers but those will
be provisioned behind the scenes if
required you just write your code in
functions and then get your task done
with that okay then for storage related
things like S3 is an object based
storage in AWS that can help you store
unlimited amounts of data uh uh object
based data in in in S3 buckets guys in
aw correct plus you have block based
related storage Services also like EBS
volumes uh which can be used as virtual
hard disk for virtual machines or shared
storage like EFS storage elastic file
storage for Linux machines or multiple
Linux machines can share that EFS
storage or FSX storage shared storage
for Windows machines and so on in AWS
okay in aure you have file shares to do
to to take care of that thing again um
right uh then you in Azure you have
other service is also that you'll cover
as your resource manager templates CRM
templates then um which is
infrastructure as a code and then uh as
your container services so you will
study about containers in kubernetes
also containers are lightweight VMS like
okay um which can host your uh
microservices based applications correct
so all of this and many many more
services you will learn guys in in AWS
and assure these are just a few that are
marked
here uh thank you so much Dr B first of
all answering shum's question and also
taking us through the tools and
platforms here and uh let's move on to
the Capstone project here the Capstone
projects here basically you can use to
Showcase your future employees which
you'll get to work on uh through this
program uh what exactly are Capstone
projects Capstone projects basically
mimic real life business scenarios for
True experience which you can Showcase
in your portfolio so considering that
you're coming from a completely
non-cloud Computing background uh the
having a capson project would definitely
help you know boost your portfolio here
and uh as we have mentioned earlier that
you get to work on industry based
Hands-On projects for your portfolio
where basically you can see the projects
which can choose to work on deploy an
online Video subscription application on
the cloud deploy uh online Healthcare
application on the cloud deploying uh
restant application to the cloud and the
last one deploying card management
application to the cloud U interestingly
we have actually covered a lot of these
project demos you know in the previous
webinars here uh which you can check out
you know I'll be sharing the link
towards it uh later and also a simply
learn Community you you get access to
with supports you hear the learner gets
access to instructors a program manager
a cohort manager uh the curriculum and
resources and learning teams and peers
you know which we have also talked about
earlier so uh the learning environment
here so the learning environment for the
program I think uh Dr pusham you have
basically taken us through the learning
environment right like basically how it
looks like yeah um I can take you
through that
Jos so we have talked about how
basically the program builds your
basically skills in cloud computing step
by step now we'll be taking you through
a quick short learning environment which
Dr Brut will be sharing his screen for
so uh you can go ahead and share your
screen Dr P sure meanwhile folks while
Dr Pam is sharing his screen uh we'll be
taking questions pretty soon uh
basically we are near to it so uh we can
see a lot of interesting questions from
your end we have tried answering few
questions uh throughout the session uh
so pleasee don't worry please have some
patience we'll answer all of your
queries so please don't worry about that
okay I'll uh yeah sure so I'll just real
quick uh get you through here okay uh so
this is the postgraduate program in
cloud computing and as you can see here
um uh will uh you have the prerequisites
Tab and then uh you get into uh the
courses tab now in courses you have the
orientation session for keltech pgp
cloud program as I already told you then
you have course one aw Solutions
architect associate then aure
administrator then uh the stuff that I
had mentioned okay apart from that if
you get into any course let's say if you
get into uh Azure uh
e104 or any course guys so you will what
you will see out there you will see
self-learning videos now the self-
learning videos are the uh lecture uh
recordings of these will contain the
recordings of uh What uh of an already
uh available good trade
that you can listen to okay pre-recorded
sessions of some good trainer that would
be there then in the live classes tab
what you will see is uh you will see the
lecture recordings of the live classes
that you will go through okay so those
will be interactive classes but even the
lecture recordings of those classes
would be available in this tab and you
can refer them uh later also correct you
will have if you have gone with multiple
classes you will see it in past classes
those recordings correct in the live
classes tab then in the assist M tabs as
I told you you'll have projects for
every uh course so you can see the
projects plus the assignments here well
um you can uh you can go through it and
you will have to solve one project and
one assignment to unlock your
certificate okay then in the reference
materials you will find ebooks projects
lab guide practices cheat sheet that you
can always download it from here and
then you can refer to that material okay
you can learn from it um now the point
is that how will you do these projects
okay so for that probably you can have
your personal AWS account and assure
account but then simply learn tells you
even if you don't have your personal
account well that's not a problem we
will provide you the sendbox environment
so that sendbox environment is available
in the form of these Labs so see I'm in
Azure course so I have got Azure Labs
here so uh in this I can just say launch
lab and then I can get into the lab and
I can do that lab correct so I don't
need to create my account on aure so
that's uh the beauty of joining the
course here you can just do it with the
sandbox environment here for no extra
cost then in the certificate section
once as I told you you will um do the
project and in some courses even the
assignment you will be able to unlock
the certificate like for this a104 aure
cert aure Course once you do the project
plus if you attend the 80% of the um um
live classes or 85% of the self-
learning videos uh plus this project if
you'll do uh then you will be able to
unlock the certificate okay so uh
because I told you for every course you
will get a certificate and once you
complete all the compulsory courses then
you get the um uh postgraduate program
in cloud computing certificate from
Caltech University correct so that is
there and like the way I told you I
shown you the LMS part for aure course
in the same way it is available for all
other courses also like AWS course and
and even the other courses also here
correct uh so that's how it goes okay
and uh uh yeah okay so so see for AWS
also it's available that way okay and um
just a
second uh like you saw for uh one
second maybe I can just refresh
it like you saw for the compulsory
courses there's a tab given for uh the
uh um elective courses also like these
are the compulsory courses then you have
elective courses also okay and in
compulsory courses as you can see the
Capstone project also so if you get into
the Capstone project um well in Capstone
project again you'll have the self-
learning video uh plus the live classes
by the mentor uh the lecture recording
of that which will help you uh in uh
mentoring as in how you can do these
Capstone project okay so that would be
there and apart from that you have the
electives also uh these courses
compulsory courses then the electives so
electives also the same LMS they have
also got like uh the same uh UI you'll
get you will get self-learning uh videos
and then uh the live classes also for
many of them you'll get it here the
lecture recordings correct and yeah so
you can go with it and then finally uh
once you have completed the required
requirement of all the courses then you
can unlock your postgraduate program in
cloud computing certificate from here
from Caltech University okay so this is
how the LMS looks like this is how it
will help you uh in your journey and
apart from this you have have this
community tab which is a very um useful
tab actually uh here you can have the
threads created now you can actually uh
uh interact with your peers with your
other Learners from your batches plus
with the trainer plus with the um simply
learn um um support staff also uh uh or
the T also uh through this community um
forum and you can get your doubts solved
you can get your issues resolved here
correct uh so this is quite useful that
way okay the community Forum plus if the
learner wants to share some extra um uh
notes with you extra material with you
he or she can do it in the community tab
can create a separate thread and thread
and can uh share that with you okay so
that is there uh okay apart from that
you have this help support uh wherein
you get I think 24 by7 support I think
you have got it if you have any queries
you can uh raise here and get the
support of the team you can chat with
the team okay so that's how uh it goes
about I think I've covered all of this
right then yeah RHA so um yeah thank you
this is day sure thank you so much Dr
Pam for taking us through the learning
environment and uh let me just stop
sharing yeah sure let me just uh share
my screen back for the folks here so
folks that was the learning environment
for you for the CTIC poster program in
cloud computing uh we will be moving on
uh to the next slide so uh here we have
global leaders and as program advisers
from CTIC Rick Hefner who's the CTIC
ctma executive director has over 40
years of experience in system
development and uh has served in
academic industrial and research
positions John vsia is a cloud computing
uh program director in CK again like
having over 30 years of experience in
working in the industry government and
higher education so the global leaders
here from CTIC make sure that simply
learn is delivering to as for the
standards of Caltech and uh moving on to
the learner outcomes here so the
Learners as I've mentioned earlier come
from different different Industries so
previous classes have consisted of
Learners from World Class organizations
and diverse Industries uh Industries
like it software bfsi e-commerce and
others and companies they come from our
IBM Oracle Microsoft deoy uh Barclays
Wells Fargo Amazon um and many more like
that uh and the success stories for a
few of the successories from a lot of
our Learners here from Ravine as we can
see that after completing the course uh
he could structure the uh basically his
own cloud Consulting vertical to offer
cloud and digital consultancy to his
customers and also today he added like
seven new Cloud curties customers with
marot Radison ooy Taj and many other
names uh next one is Rajiv here Raj
Shasta basically he says that it was an
incredible learning experience he liked
the course content and also the live
demo on AWS and Azor which We have
basically covered as well in the program
part the instructors were very
proficient and also have answered all of
his questions the certification help him
get a job uh basically and with a good
salary hike here so and also jumna here
shares that the course helped her with
her career growth and she got a decent
job offer with a 50% salary hike after a
career break so that makes it pretty
interesting uh moving on the job ass
Services which we have shared earlier
what you get from Simply is partnered
with IM jobs here
in fact Raji was my
learner oh interesting I'm so sorry so
I'll just share back my screen once
again so sorry for the technical hiccup
here I'm just sharing back my screen
once again
quickly yeah I'll talking about the job
assist Services here uh so the job
Business Services which we have uh we
have partnered with IM jobs here and in
this you get access to premium IM jobs
portal uh resume review and rewrite
services and one-on-one interview
Service as well as you're trying to get
out there and basically get a job uh in
cloud computing U I think uh we have one
interesting question here Dr purushotam
from Ahmed Faruk uh I've actually dm'd
you on the chat here but I'll just ping
you again because we have a lot of
questions in the Q&A and we'll start
taking those questions now uh slowly
slowly so uh if you a web designer uh
can you work with Cloud if yes what part
are you going to be on yeah so if you're
a web designer of course you can work in
cloud and then you can create your own
websites you can host them up so the
part that you are in uh out is like you
can um you can just host your websites
in Cloud so once you have created your
website if you're a web designer you
have designed your website you have your
website running how you can host it in
Cloud you will study it okay so maybe
you can host it on um the servers
virtual servers like uh the ec2
instances or VMS in aure or you can even
uh host it on um container based uh uh
instances okay containers uh kubernetes
or maybe in in Lambda function S3
buckets so so you have multiple ways of
hosting it in cloud based on different
requirements you can decide where you
want to host it and then you can even
provide the domain names to your uh to
your website um with with the help of
DNS service in Cloud um like you can
make use of azure DNS owns in in Azure
or or Route 53 service in AWS for for
providing names to your website okay um
so yeah uh you can uh so for that you
can actually register those names also
uh so with with with any domain register
like GoDaddy big rock freom or or any
other or even the Route 53 AWS provides
you the service of uh registering your
domains also correct so
uh so yes uh you can use it that
way uh thank you so much Dr Pam for
answering that I hope Ahmed faru that
answers your question please do let us
know in the chat or in the Q&A box here
uh we'll take few more questions uh
because folks have been waiting for us
to take questions so we'll just not take
it towards the end we'll take it right
away uh so uh we have a question from uh
uh I'm not able to Moine I think the
name is from the email ID which I'm able
to make out as a software developer in
embedded system what can can be the way
forward in Cloud Dr P okay so embedded
system as a software engineer in
embedded system what can be the way okay
so now uh see if you are an embedded
systems engineer okay so um you can get
into the embeded is it only me I not
able to hear Dr B
uh am I not
audible no no no no no you're audible
please a okay yeah so uh if you are an
embedded systems engineer okay so you
can you can get into the embedded
related services in Cloud especially you
can get into iot related services in
Cloud okay and uh um you can do chip
level programming also and then you can
uh you can store that data of your chip
level programming of your iot related uh
programming in in in Cloud very easily
so there are a lot of iot related stuff
iot related services that are available
so if you are an embedded systems
engineer I you can get into iot related
services in cloud and that can solve
your
purpose uh thank you so much Dr P for
answering that I hope moing that answers
your question please do let us know on
chat or in the Q&A box here uh so the
next one which we have here is by Rajiv
Pak uh he says that I am a professional
with 3.7 years in
M365 uh support uh since I started my
journey I have aspired to be a cloud
Artic architect and I would like to know
what the career prospects in the field
are and how should I take it further
from here also you mentioned that the
90% of companies will move to the cloud
so seemingly the migration projects will
reduce and the job prospective prospects
will reduce as well so what what would
you be your comment there okay so see I
would say uh first of all uh if you want
to become a cloud architect with based
on the number of years of experience
that you have stated immediately you may
not not get into the cloud architect
role but yes you can always go with the
cloud architect certification if you are
interested in Cloud architect role and
initially you can become a cloud
engineer okay and then subsequently uh
you can you can involve into design
decisions being a cloud engineer also
and then subsequently you can get into
the cloud architect role with good
number of years of experience that is
the first part okay and then the second
part is that uh 90% of the companies
will move towards the cloud so seemingly
migration projects will reduce see um
it's not all about migration projects in
Cloud uh see it's about migration right
now uh the the the companies are moving
towards Cloud so yes there are a lot of
migration related things that are
happening and for doing those things as
I give as I gave you the examples like
um xaby exabytes uh uh volumes of data
also if you have in your on premisis
environment in your organization your
complete data center you want to move it
to Cloud so probably if it takes 26
years otherwise to move it which is
which seems really in infusible to do it
then in in cloud with let's say in AWS
with snowmobile service you can do it in
less than 6 months okay so that's the
beauty but the point is that once they
will be moved towards Cloud so then
these migration projects may be reduced
but then the migration projects are not
just for like moving your data into
Cloud even for cloud modernization also
companies move towards Cloud so see uh
the the things will keep on increasing
and and and and even apart from
migration related stuff there are a lot
of other things that you can get into
Cloud once you are in Cloud you have so
many features that you can use and so
many are evolving also so many good
features uh you have and are coming up
and even the security part there's a lot
of scope um that uh the the companies
offer uh or or the cloud providers offer
to make your data secure there so they
are maturing day by day they are
providing more such related things to
you so yes the job prospects will not
reduce at all because it's not just
about the migration engineer uh that you
can get into Cloud you have so many
letters and if the companies are more
into the cloud well the job prospects
will even increase not just reduce
because if uh let's say if 90% of
companies will move towards Cloud so
they want their Engineers to be cloud
ready they want their Engineers uh to
work onto those Cloud platforms so they
want their Engineers to have the know
how have the working environment in the
cloud domain otherwise how would they
hire them or how would they work with
them correct yeah yeah so it would
increase thank you so much uh for Dr BR
for you know giving a detailed
explanation I hope rajif that answers
your question please do let us know in
chat I think we'll take one last
question before we move forward uh
because folks have been curiously waited
for waiting for you know for the queries
to get answered so Nar here has asked
like how uh we can move from security
cloud and devops to Dev uh
eops yeah yeah okay uh so yeah so it's
pretty simple I mean see if you have the
knowledge of devops related Services
plus security related Services well
that's a good mix I mean if you have uh
the the the knowledge of both the things
then you can get into devops okay so uh
then you can always transition into it
because it's all about automation with
devops and then security related aspects
you will study in the in the in the in
the in the security related services so
that way you can you can easily
transition yourself if you have both the
knowledge of both the
services thank you so much for answering
that Dr R once again and I hope that
answers your question uh I think we'll
take more questions maybe uh if we have
any questions you know towards the end
so uh meanwhile uh we would love to know
your interest would you like to enroll
into the CTIC Cloud pgp uh program uh so
here you will be getting a bonus offer
as well for attending the webinar so you
can Avail that by clicking on yes as the
option and we have talked about the
skills we have talked about the projects
you can add to your portfolio Serv
program we have talked about the
industry projects and also a Capstone
project we have talked about the career
paths you can take up in 2024 here and
uh we basically have talked about how
you can transition from coming from a
certain career to you know taking up
cloud computing as a career what are the
salaries you can expect in cloud
computing so we would love to know your
interest in enrollment into the CTIC
postgraduate program in cloud computing
so you can see quick options here yes
and no uh if you click on yes you can
Avail the bonus offer in uh basically in
the next one year it will be available
for you to Avail in case you're not
planning to start immediately which that
is something also I'll be asking in the
upcoming slides when do you plan to
enroll so uh and also sharing the
upcoming course and the program fee and
also details about the program link and
I know that folks have joined uh from
different different parts of the world
here not only India so I'll be sharing
the program link which basically you can
check out and for your own region and
check out the fee as well so don't worry
about that uh as I was speaking I can
see uh like the responses coming in is
the most for enrollments towards the
CTIC uh postgraduate program here in
cloud computing uh so that's great uh
but meanwhile I'll just ask few folks
who have not shared the responses for
the poll here before we move on to the
next part of the enrollment steps of the
program uh please quickly go and share
your responses for the poll here so are
you interested in Rolling to CTIC postc
program and cloud computing so let's not
forget the bonus offer as well you'll be
getting for attending this webinar
today oh I can see uh Norman has replied
on the chat here to us that uh
interested in joining the program so
please uh please go and quickly vote Yes
if you have already done it so that's
great you uh basically I'll be sharing
what is the process moving forward so
thank you so much for sharing that was
on the chat here as well
and also if any questions about the
program in general please let us know
we'll be taking those questions
upcoming okay I think I'll just give 10
seconds more for the poll here uh before
we move on to the enrollment steps of
the
program so once again like would you
like to enroll into CTIC cloud computing
uh postgraduate program
here so you can see a quick B on your
screen
also as we were talking we have gotten
almost more than 90% of the interest
towards enrollment so that's that's
great I can see a lot of folks basically
expiring to become a cloud Community
expert uh so that's great and we'll just
give some more time for folks uh who are
still thinking about it I think only few
folks are left so I'll just give few
more seconds for the folks here before
we move on to the enrollment steps of
the
program and and also I'll just share the
link towards the program in case you
want to check out the program details in
your own country region so I'll just
quickly share the link also for the
program so you check
out I've shared the link here and also
uh I'll just quickly share if you have
any questions about the program uh you
can always reach out to us at ask
usimply learn.net and I'll share that
email ID the chat here in case you have
any questions about the program or
anything in general not only program so
I think we've gotten uh the responses
here on the poll here uh so I'll be
ending the poll in 5 seconds so 5
Seconds more for few folks basically who
are still thinking about it uh and also
thank you so much for folks who have
already shared their interest towards
enrollment so I'll just give five
seconds more for the poll so five 4 3 2
1 let me quickly end the poll and thank
you so much for sharing the respon on
the poll here I saw a lot lot of
interest coming towards the enrollment
part so I'll be taking you through the
enrollment step for the folks who have
already share their interest with us so
uh there are three simple easy steps you
need to follow for the enrollment here
you need to submit an application you
can apply at
ask.net I have just shared the email ID
on the chat here and uh the next step
here is scch CDM reviews your
qualification based on the eligibility
and pre sites I've shared with you
earlier and based on that your basically
you be getting an learning consultant
will be contacting you uh with
admissions offer from Simply learn and
also you can basically Avail the bonus
offer there so don't forget that I think
folks asked about the program fee and
when is the upcoming uh schedule cohart
for the program as well uh folks who
basically want to join immediately so
I'll just quickly take you through that
as well uh so the program fee for Indian
folks here is 1 lakh 159,000 including
taxes IA and uh I think someone asked
about the if there is an Emi option
available you know they would like to
take up so we have that you can
basically go for financing options
available for as low as
5,411 basically INR per month and also
the upcoming cohort which we have uh the
classes will be starting from 2nd of
December this year and the orientation
induction session will be happening on
14th of November uh this year and we
have limited cohorts per basically
limited seats per coh and we only take
25 to 30 folks per C in order to make
sure that you're getting all the
attention that is required while you're
taking up this program uh so I'll be
asking you about when do you plan to
enroll in the upcoming slides you can
basically decide based on that you know
when do you plan to enroll and as
mentioned earlier that basically uh in
case you have any questions you can
always reach out to us at ask us at
s.net so you will see a quick on your
screen here uh basically when do you
plan to enroll how soon do you plan to
enroll so there are four quick options
here uh so for folks who basically have
already asked me that when is the next
upcoming Cod they would love to join so
I I would recommend to select the
immediate option here the first one and
uh there are three other options in case
you are still planning on you know uh
like you know when to join So within
three months within six months and the
last one more than six months from now
is something much much more suitable for
you so this is highly recommended for
the folks uh who have already shared
interest towards enrollment in the
previous po here so please do let us
know so this will give us a better idea
when to reach out and also you can Avail
the bonus offer you'll be getting for
attending this webinar here so I'll just
give 10 seconds more because as I was
speaking folks have already started
sharing the responses for the poll here
uh and we'll be moving on uh to the Q&A
part if you have any questions but we
actually have covered most of the
questions here you know in this limited
time because we have already extended
the session by 20 minutes that to thanks
to Dr purushotam uh he actually has let
us extend the session so again like
thank you for that Dr Pam taking us
taking you know 20 minutes more for the
session and okay I'll just give five
seconds more for the poll here before we
close this
poll so five 4 3 2 1 let me quickly end
the poll uh thank you so much for
sharing that with us now moving on to
the last poll of the session uh where we
would love to know that uh you have
already shared the interest towards
enrollment and also have let us know
when do you plan to enroll so uh do you
need assistance into enrolling uh into
the CTIC post C program in cloud
computing so there are two quick options
here you can select the most suitable
option for you if you want assistance
you can select the option yes uh folks
who are replying on chat here while
while I was speaking so I hope you have
answered it on the poll like more than
six months from now you have answered
here on the chat here but no worries
we'll pick it up from the chat so not to
mention but please do uh basically give
you responses in the PO here that really
helps us you know like uh reaching out
to you based on the responses you have
given given us so I'll just give 10
seconds more for the poll
here and we have extended 20 minutes for
the session but I still see stickiness
of the crowd here so that's great uh so
thank you so much for staying with us
while we extend the session by few
minutes for addressing your queries here
yes we have gotten plenty of questions
on the Q&A box but we only have limited
time to answer that so we do these
webinars like almost every day of the
week so uh this is not the last time
you're seeing us you will see Dr
purushotam in many more upcoming
webinars here uh so I'll just share the
upcoming webinars link here which you
can check out and check out other
webinars as well you can register for
that and I'll just quickly end the poio
because I can see folks have already
shared the responses for the assistance
poll here so I'll just end the poll and
uh we'll move on to the towards the end
of the program so uh first of all would
like to thank Dr pusham for taking the
time out and taking us to this career
Master Class of cloud computing uh would
you like to say something to the crowd
here before we end the session yeah
thank you thank you Rasha for giving the
opportunity and yeah I would like to
tell you guys thanks a lot for being
here and uh for listening to us and yes
uh one thing I would like to tell you
you will have a great time if you'll
join this program and do attend uh the
other webinars that we do take up here
um uh believe me uh if you'll join my
webinar I hope you will have a great
time uh especially the um technical
webinars that um maybe I'll be having
some few in the upcoming sessions
correct so uh so yeah uh so I would
invite you to join my webinars and uh
the other webinars as well and you'll
have a great time here and yes of course
if you'll join the course you'll have a
great deal ahead correct thank you agree
agree to that we have a lot of Industry
Trends and career Trends upcoming you
know in the coming months so again like
thank you Dr Pam once again and thank
you uh folks for joining us and uh being
an active audience here and a very warm
audience with a lot of interesting
questions we've gotten from you uh I
understand we were not able to answer
all of them because we have a limited
time and we already extended the session
so apologies for that uh and also I
think a lot of you folks have asked if
the recording of the session is
available so yes you'll be getting the
recording of the session over mail uh
and in case you want to go through it
again in case you have missed something
you can go through it again so don't
worry about that so again once again uh
thank you everyone for joining and we'll
be coming up with more interesting
webinars just like this in the upcoming
months also with Dr purushotam here so
thank you once again thank you thank
you